so tell us a little bit about the
journey of this Yeti story that the
blank screen that you started with blank
canvas yeah so a lot of times when you
are developing projects they'll have you
come into the picture development slate
the studio as well and so the one idea
that really appealed to me was just a
Yeti movie and this was before the other
Yeti movies and it was just a blank
slate it was a blank canvas there was no
story involved and so I drove home that
night and my brain was just kind of
spinning with ideas I there was a couple
things that really jumped out to me I
ran home and I kind of googled Yeti and
what came up was really interesting
because there's not much lore about them
their fabled to live on Mount Everest
their fabled to be kind of ferocious
everyone's seen their footprints in the
snow but there was really nothing so I
thought well this is a great opportunity
to come up with the Yeti lore that might
be the lore that kids live with for the
rest of their lives you know and the
other thing that was really appealing to
me to other things quick was just that I
wanted a really strong female lead that
was important to me and I wanted a role
model that was more of a tomboy and I
grew up in Ventura not too far from here
surfing you know skateboarding camping
and I threw on whatever was laying on my
floor pretty much and I just really was
not into kind of the princess movies
because I just felt like there was no
role model for me and so that was really
important to me and then of course I've
grown up and I have still now giant dogs
and that was actually a huge inspiration
for just the beginning part of Everest
to kind of have him walking for is
instead of the expected two legs and two
to make him playful and to have that
nonverbal communication that we have
with our pets so all those things were
kind of the early beginnings of the idea
so how did you guys work as as producers
to create this workflow and also to
create this sense of cultural tapestry I
guess is what I'm looking for him does
that make sense I think we were
collaborators first and
so you know we couldn't make this
endeavor at all without talking to each
other every single day and I was at
DreamWorks of course in Palin was
working with Perl and so it's nice to
hear that it felt very organic I think
we were you know it was hard it was hard
because we wanted to do it right and so
we leaned on our friends at Perl and I
leaned on Palin to really keep us on
track as far as you know being authentic
and and and in doing things the right
way and I think the surprise was of that
in the end the story was so Universal
when we were worried that maybe would
sue my lease do they seem like they're
like I don't know American kids they
seem like they're Chinese kids and we
shared so much in common and that's the
beautiful part of this story is that yes
we do have things in common we have very
specific cultural differences but we can
find the things in common and hopefully
end up with a gorgeous movie and a
beautiful story I think one of the
things that helped is that this film was
really born inside both studios it
wasn't at one place and then you know we
all know many co productions where is
perhaps developed by an American company
and then a Chinese financier comes in
and then suddenly the characters have to
go to China for a random reason or you
know this film from the beginning from
inception Jill had this idea of taking
the eddy home to the Himalayas China was
a natural geographical place that they
would live and come from and so I think
that it was very organic from the
beginning and one of the core beliefs
that we have at Pearl is that stories
can be very culturally specific and
authentic but at the same time be
globally relatable because of what they
are about Thea matically and I think
Jill has women's such a beautiful themes
into this film that it doesn't matter if
your grandmother in Russia or you know a
little boy in Brazil you definitely
don't have to be Chinese at all it all
speaks to you so Chloe what appealed to
you about the role and how did you
approach being ready to do that in what
I assume was the room of the microphone
yeah it was it's
it's crazy how just when I went in to
meet with everyone for the role
originally I left and called my agents
and I was like if I don't get that I
should just quit acting because I this
care there's I don't know anyone who
this was me it just felt like me it felt
like a I lived in Shanghai with my
grandma when I was 15 years old and I I
grew up with six brothers I was a huge
tomboy I wore all their hand-me-downs I
was always odd jobs and always just like
a self-proclaimed loner that's exactly
who I was and who I still feel on the
inside despite this ill-equipped outfit
for this panel really hard time he's
like taking pictures if you see me in my
mom anyway
the it was it was really like a it was
me and Jill in the room we you know I
started this three years ago and so the
the reference of even just knowing what
was in you know if I was leaning down to
talk to something or if it was 10 feet
away there's there's nothing so you as
an actor you are a completely stripped
of anything that kind of you know you're
not in hair and makeup you're not in a
wardrobe there's nothing and it that was
that was interesting but I was really
lucky in the fact that the core of who
the character was and the spirit of her
was so just well I felt so similar to
who I was that I didn't feel I was lucky
to be able to lean on that instead of
anything else because everything else
kind of fell into place after that and
you know it I I grew up and I had no you
know I was a tomboy who is half Chinese
and was culturally raised you know
people are like you don't look Chinese
even Chinese people like you not Chinese
all the time my grandma says I don't
look Chinese ever and she's Chinese and
she knows that I am but I was raised
much more culturally Chinese than what
people kind of expect when they look at
me
and that's part of that's part of being
culturally different that people don't
think about you know they think about
the aesthetic part they think about
other things but
don't think about the nuance of the way
that people that you don't turn your
back and talk like that in an argument
with the Chinese parent if you want to
you know survive there's a lot of
different things that I was that I was
raised you know even just like at the
dinner table you know making you're
gonna feed your elders first the way
that they do at the end of the movie
there's like all these little nuances
that I felt so seen by when I when I saw
the film and that were so effortless to
me and so like I got I would get like
jittery about how exciting it was to not
have to you know to think about little
kids bringing bow to school like Charles
Ababa the pork buns and not getting made
fun of the way that I did because it's
it's such an authentic thing but it also
was so effortlessly just kind of in the
film yet the story was so universal so
it that that part is really exciting to
think that maybe now someone could bring
bow to school and it wouldn't won't be
some you know they won't make fun of you
what's the thing that you were most
concerned or that you worked the hardest
on and that you felt that you somehow
conquered in your work for me this is
the first time ever a modern-day Chinese
family has been featured in a global
animated film and yeah you can clap for
that it was so profound that notion
actually I'm still kind of in disbelief
that this weekend the number one box
office film features a modern-day
Chinese family it's hard not to feel so
emotional about that growing up never
seeing someone that looked like myself
in film and television it's kind of been
a life mission that I really believe in
and you know we of course hope this film
is really successful in China and plays
well in China but I think my personal
connection is more for with Asian
Americans having grown up here in this
country and that experience and one of
the most gratifying thing for me about
screenings I've gone to
the Asian women in particular that have
come up to me and said this movie is
means everything to me
this movie is I've never felt seen in
this way for my children to see what's
on the screen to see your role in this
film you know the the phrase I keep
hearing is that if you if you don't see
it you can't be it and how deeply
meaningful that is to the community and
so the pressure of okay this is the
first time and wanting to do it right in
a way that was gonna feel true and
authentic and resonate with that
audience was so so important to me and
the fact that people seem to be
connecting with it and responding to it
is probably the most meaningful thing of
all it's hard unless you're an
asian-american to really understand the
duality of what being asian-american
means and what being Asian Asian means
because when you're asian-american you
are a minority and obviously when you're
from Asia you're not and so to hit it on
the head like to be able to make
something that is good is such a
universal you know film that works both
here and China that's a really hard
thing to actually actually get done
because culturally Asian Americans and
and/or Chinese Americans at least in my
opinion and Chinese people who live in
China there it's a very very different
thing there's a lot of similarities but
there's a lot of things that you don't
you know when you're growing up and you
don't have representation you really
think that you can't do the things that
because you are not white enough you are
not this enough you are not that enough
and they don't have that as much there
obviously so it's it's that's that
that's been something to have people
come up and speak about that in
particular has been really really
powerful and it's you know film is so
impactful obviously everyone in this
room knows that but this is animation is
really the first time people see film
that's if it's your first it's the
entryway it's the gateway drug and so to
have this be so impactful for young kids
it's that's been that's been really cool
especially for both definitely thank you
all for being here today